this morning France is waking up after
another night of clashes around the
country in Lil and Toulouse and
predictably here in montair the Paris
suburb that was the Catalyst for all the
disorder that has followed behind me
over there you can see fires burning in
the middle of the street we can see Riot
police officers there and in fact just
walking past us here and the smell of
tear gas still lingers this is not going
to end easily and why well because this
area and all of France has now seen that
video of a French police officer
shooting a teenager in a car just a mile
or so from where I'm standing now that
has been condemned by the president by
the interior Minister by prominent
individuals including kylian mbappe the
super famous French footballer who grew
up also in a French suburb and what has
happened is a synthesis of all the
discontent by people who live here about
what they see is the brutality of the
police about the way that they think
that the system has forgotten and hasn't
given them jobs or education has left
them behind in the economy and that
discontent has clearly simmered and
boiled over here driven by the fury over
the killing of this 17 year old what
will now happen is a March from the
prefecture here in non-terre led by the
mother of the teenager who died the
question here in Monte and for all of
France is whether this discontent will
continue or whether it will simmer out
and right now nobody knows the answer to
that